[Music]
you and your family could travel coast
to coast without a single
tank of gas on board a high-speed train
i am obsessed with trains
i love trains how long is it going to
take before i get my high-speed rail
well i'll tell you i can't wait i feel
the same way you do
[Music]
in liberals dreams this is what
america's high-speed rail network looks
like
was the headline of a slate article
about this map by graphic designer and
transit advocate
alfred two that was eight years ago but
the map has started to get attention
amid thoughts of new high-speed rail
funding
in january 2020 i want her so [ __ ]
much was retweeted or quote tweeted 53
000 times from an account with under a
thousand followers
the user then reply tweeted with a
rendering of the us if we had a
high-speed rail system
well a lot of people on twitter say
hyperbolic things for retweets and jokes
even transportation secretary pete
budadich shared a recent vox article
featuring the map
saying gen z is dreaming big it's time
we all did the same
what these people may not be paying
attention to is that in the real world
high-speed rail is wildly expensive
and predictably destructive to
communities building it requires
bulldozing and disrupting neighborhoods
to lay down the track the transportation
secretary's definition of dreaming big
is applying 20th century technology to
the problems of the 21st
when funding for the initial part of the
california high-speed rail line was
voted on in 2008 it was supposed to link
los angeles with san francisco for about
33 billion dollars
and take about a decade to complete as
the years dragged on the cost ballooned
to 100 billion at one point and the
project had to be scaled back
significantly
i like trains i like high-speed trains
even better
in 2019 after governor gavin newsom
replaced jerry brown
he scaled the project back to a section
running between merced and bakersfield
current project as planned would cost
too much
and respectfully take too long what
gavin newsom has done is he's spitting
jerry brown's eye
newsome basically said is you know jerry
this is your little choo choo and
you know what i can't afford to pay for
your dream joel cotkin is a fellow of
urban studies at chapman university
and a longtime critic of high-speed rail
this is the ultimate train to nowhere
going from two places that first of all
don't have any particular relationship
with each other you have to get a car
once you get to the station and it
doesn't go to any job center that
anyone's going to commute to so it's
really almost like a
vestigial organ that's been left you
know it's like the
transportation appendix
while people dream on twitter about
high-speed trains connecting american
cities
california's project is an example of
what it actually costs to build
what we're talking about is a vision for
high-speed rail in america
in 2009 president barack obama proposed
building 8
600 miles of high-speed rail and
received 10.1 billion dollars from
congress toward that goal
12 years later there's nothing to show
after the money went to upgrading amtrak
instead
the cato institute's rando o'toole
estimates that based on the cost
overruns and setbacks of the california
project building 8
600 miles of high-speed rail would have
cost well over 1 trillion dollars
i don't think there should be any
additional funding because i think it
has been poorly managed
and i think the project needs to be
cancelled baruch feigenbaum is the
senior managing director of
transportation policy at the reason
foundation which publishes reason tv
feigenbaum says we could be on the verge
of a dramatic shift in how americans
work and live that makes high-speed rail
even more absurd but high-speed rail
typically is
business travelers and if we're going to
see more substitution with zoom
and more of meetings that are remote and
fewer in-person trips
that's going to make high-speed rail
even less viable than it already is
we've got to take things to the next
level you look at what our counterparts
in japan
are able to enjoy but really across the
world place like
the uk or or turkey i want the us to be
leading the world comparing the u.s to
europe and japan
well we are not those other countries we
have an interstate system
we have much lower population density
overall less density means fewer
passengers
which means less revenue modern trains
typically require massive taxpayer
subsidies
the same is expected for california's
high-speed rail so you're actually
having some subsidies from lower income
californians
subsidizing business travel which seems
to me to be a very odd policy
right now there simply isn't a path
governor newsom
has taken some very interesting
positions from my point to get some good
position when he came into office
he basically pared down the rail system
and said we are going to focus on the
central valley
we are not going to focus on san
francisco and los angeles at that time
because we don't have the money and
basically because high-speed rail is
something for
upper-income californians who are not
the group that voted for me anyway
and not really my priority is you know
someone who's pretty far to the left and
pretty progressive we'll
see what happens i don't think he would
turn down
federal money for the california
high-speed rail project
this is the future this is the future of
transportation in california 100
electrified system cleaning up the air
newsome along with a few other
politicians are already vying for those
federal dollars not that the white house
at least in theory
is behind the idea there is a
transportation
reauthorization bill that is the same as
the infrastructure bill it's passed
every five to six years by congress
traditionally there has not been money
for high-speed rail in that bill
the other way they could do it is
supplemental funding
feigenbaum says neither is likely to
happen in the near future nor two new
bills that would fund an interstate
high-speed rail network likely to pass
one that would provide 32 billion and
the other 205 billion
so the question is where will there be
money what we're seeing
is a lot of talk about high-speed rail
money but not a lot of action
i want the us to be leading the world
when it comes to access to high-speed
rail and and i think we have a real
opportunity to do that especially with
the
bipartisan appetite for real investments
that we have before us this year
president biden promised to make sure
that america had the cleanest
safest and fastest rail system in the
world during the 2020 campaign
as congress plans to vote on a massive
infrastructure bill that president biden
has already signaled should include some
type of high-speed rail
politicians should pay more attention to
california's costly disaster
than a map they find on twitter